Today I just chucked out a few topics, really just to help you
guys stay informed. So I checked on there, we talked
about trimming, we talked about CSC rules that are in effect
already and a bit about weight and how that affects the sport.
And then we can open up other topics as you wish afterwards.
How many people here do chiming quite actively already?
So quite a few. And how many have never seen
trimming before? Don't do it.
Yeah, there's a few don't trimming.
So it's becoming a very important topic in the sport at
the moment. So for example, in the the
category ones, so last week on European Championships in every
PwC, they're now checking 3 wings every day.
I tend to aim for three wings a week.
And historically I might just do every other comp, I will do a
few. But trimmings becoming a big
deal these days in the rules, it's always been a big deal for
two liners, not for three liners, but in the rules now
it's becoming more focus. So historically, I don't know
when you guys started, I started flying in the early 90s and the
trimming and then days if your wing, if your line shrunk by the
thought of 5 centimeters, it didn't matter the wing through
anyway. And if you wanted to re trim it,
you used to tie the risers to a tree.
I want to open this now. We trimmed our wing, he tied the
risers to a tree, he went to your wing and he just pulled
every line and you feel it giving until it stopped.
Then that's it. I'm back in trail now.
What we didn't realise is the next couple of flights here the
shrunk again modern trimming. It's about allowing for the
shrinkage, let the wings shrink to its natural position and then
you trim to make that a flyable instead.
But modern 3 liners again, it's not too crazy.
I don't know is Bruce seen the room very probably tell us more,
but I I haven't flown 3 liners for a long time, but I would
imagine a couple of centimeters is still horribly acceptable for
a majority with three liners, two liners, sports wings.
You even have a centimetre change and the road play.
If you start getting onto your enzos with your boomerangs, we
can get away with a centimetre, but they're not very nice to fly
now and in some scenarios they may not be safe.
If you get a big collapse and it's too slow and too slow is
where they go when they change. True they don't recover so well,
but also they don't fly as nice but you're thermally they don't
bite into thermals, they just get mocked back instead of going
forwards driving in. So trimming is not just a
wobbles thing, it's about flying.
But that said, all this trimming we can do, don't worry too much
about the numerous if your wing flies nice, don't touch it.
It's all about it flying nice. It's not about it being a
specific trim to be at its best. SO focusing on an Enzo, which is
where the majority of trimming knowledge comes from.
The Enzo's been out now for nearly ten years, the Enzo 3,
and we can stay within one or two millimetres where the sweet
spot is. So are the Group One with centre
section about 6 or 7 mil faster to the manufacturer dictated was
a lovely sweet spot. As long as the rest of the stuff
matches it. It fights beautifully, it climbs
beautifully, it's got good speed so that's a nice place to be on.
I was Europeans as the team leader for the British last
week. I have 7 British pilots I was
managing. Because of the focus on the
rules we decided to check all of our team to make sure they can
fly and we actually found the only thing was flying 18
millimetres slow on his wing. Never trimmed it since he bought
it over a year ago and he said it probably explains why he is
having trouble firmly. One of them was 14 mil slow.
Another one there's a live trim with it for you.
Another one has the six numbers you're after, you have 111111.
I've never seen the room so perfect.
You've brought the fastest trim. But the question to him is you
enjoy it, Yes, leave it then Perfect.
That's what manufacturer want to do to have thereabouts.
So that's good. And actually our trim team, we
never speeded anyone past 7 millimetres at that time. 7
millimetres fast and that's that means alternate attack.
All these measurements, it doesn't matter how long the
lines are. And actually the length of your
lines changes daily when you fly avoided to humidity and
temperature. What you're interested in is how
much shorter the A's are front relative to the B rises back.
So the shorten the A's to the wing will fly faster or if you
lengthen the B's, the wing will be faster.
So that's that's what we're looking at is what is that trim
And you get into then things like how stable is that trim?
Well that comes back to all our knowledge based on Enzo 3,
literally all trimming vines around an Enzo 3 and the other
wing is pretty much a bit of a guess.
So I mean I can, I designed the SRS trimmer which half of what
is sold as one through the SRS accounts just to give you SRS
electric profit. And the reason why I did it like
that was because I can find it hilarious all the PwC used the
SRS trimmer walk brain. But if you walk into the average
headquarters of the PwC any day, there's three or four PwC pilots
trimming with the SRS trimmer. So yeah.
So that was designed again around that and our knowledge
and what the Sport has done, the PwC last year start of this
season changed it so that the maximum accelerator you can have
is 10 millimetres fast. And CLBL adopted the same this
year, 10 millimetres fast. Looking at the history of why
Borg it why why you end up the earth.
I'll use that quad to sit down, but you didn't hear me on the
back. We're going to leave that limit.
I'll switch to that. Isn't it?
So the reason it's it was felt limited.
It has come in stricter than before.
Originally we had a 20 mil Linux on the fast.
Well, it's found that are the top top pilots.
So not wide pick on names particularly, but as long as you
can. I'll be a Baptist.
I know not the French team we took love one or two of the
British team, they were going off to about 18 then litres
fast, which is a very, very salary to win.
That is an extra speed like when they flied also gives them a bit
of work if and when they get blown out was we will not
recover for the critical out easily.
So you've got to be a very skilled idea to deal with that.
But the whole point of these tolerances in the first place
was just to allow for manufacturing tolerances as you
you either make your wound frowning mice or even allow
those any changes in the trim to stay close to what the
manufacturer intended. But the rules are being abused
by many pilots to their fast to win.
And I'm sure many of you look you lots of cops now.
But the person who wins a task he is.
He is a skilled fighter, sure, but it's often about who has
fastest wing on final glide. Well, you get to that last
turtle. That is still 30 highlights in
the league. Avenue of 10 colour supplies
winner. The first over the line not
allowing the league out points is usually the one with the
fastest wing. And so on the cat one last week.
They've now developed a sheet they publish daily which shows
about 20 miners, the top 20 fastest in the final blows.
They show you the last five Polish sections to go to squeeze
and what speed averaged over 5 days.
So they know the fastest wing from that.
They know the suddenly swing on the trim or under the factors.
He started for one day last week.
We had 68 K of H. He will take 1K of H.
That was pretty good for almost all the Enzos and then there was
1 notable 1/5 pair makes faster. It's that means we're millions
of thugs though, and how the hell did we do it?
That was that mean they've got the answer to the four sure it's
malt general tolerances and they were then taken in the three
Laguna the past this win and where they decided the 3rd and
then checking it and we have the penalties were great pinners in
this last week and further well, he's shooting.
There's a few other ways of shooting as well and even
altering trim would have to be visible several ways to do it is
SRSI don't think we're really seeing any of this stuff.
It might be going on a little bit, but I don't think cleaning
it big enough for bandage on sports going forwards, but it
will come. You sure it will come because in
the coming gears next year we have we blow a sports spiral
with the SRS 2.9 a little after and then the 20 to 20 to 9
probably may be 20 to 8. There'll be 1/2 stream on squad
championships. There's time to start denying
the over gear World Championships run by Anthony Ali
scores and now the state's again very highly of the amount of
actress you've already seen the money was being poured into the
SRS or the amount of actress the three live well while every
politician and that there's a lot of bloody focus for the
manufacturers. How we're doing as Alex will be
high there soon. So so that's all a broader idea
of what the trillion is about for the trillion specifically,
it's just the running back Lancet of the background of the
other stuff and but I'll just give you an idea this my ideas
for it. So several shrivels on barf.
It's at least you're running through this one.
Most important things about Shrimmer are fully selectrical.
So this has to be exactly 90°, but also Logan Shrini and his
standing we're not using rails because this is designing to
grow in suitcase to gather around the world.
So we've got it else Shrini standing over here exactly 90°
as board and it has to be so accurate.
It usually stand 10 centimeters. The solid layer you can get up
to two millimetres variation. Actually it spoiled about 1.6
mil variations during that side and that side to dummy and put a
side on it. Well, I was just putting 10
centimetres wrong and even standing 10 centimetres higher
in the horde you're firing down in it.
There's about 1 1/2 mil difference between the swap and
the whopping now. It doesn't sound much for what
are you working towards a 10 milliliter limit and you know if
you want to fly this set and go fast, it's about important.
So setting yourself up all these things by forces and you're fine
with this one. The most common laser, which is
just eared is fine. It is so laser laser most common
grand prequel barley is it glues.
You can sit into your laptop views easily.
You'll find with this laser, so red pointer, it slots into
there, it holds, it points to the other side of the room.
So I've tried to broad your eyes, but it shows you where to
stand of that size of the room. So the first thing you should do
is slot and release the ring here.
Wherever it's eyes over there, it tells you where to stand.
Get exactly knight and grease. So that's probably something
that most of you don't do. I'm guessing at the very least
you should look visually down the centre and make sure you're
aligned with it. That way you're more likely to
get accurate readings. If you want to see if your
laser's any good, it doesn't matter if it's getting the
measurements 10 centimeters wrong doesn't matter in a
slightest because we're already looking for a change of angle
attack. We don't care how far away the
wing is, so you're not looking for you.
Don't necessarily need to worry about if I fart at that wall.
Do I need to get the tape measure out and see if the
wall's the same distance? You're looking for a Does it
give the same reading every single time?
So for that we just put it on the tables, fire a wall and
press the button 10 times. Do I get the same reading each
time? So I I wrote that as a procedure
for CIBL recently. They now run that test on their
laser and they were getting 10 measurements .3 of a millimetre
is a standard deviation and for the extremes 1 millimetre.
So it's pretty really repeatable because some teams then are
swelled to 10 mil limit because that means we can have 11 mil.
No, because 0 millimetres is what the wing is supposed to be.
You've already got 10 mil tolerance, so the one mil now at
raw laser is fine. So that ones are in there.
What else? If if you failed, 10.1 is a
failed or CIDL if you failed, you were allowed to show them
how you trimmed just in case you did something different.
And that's just looking to see if you're cheating or just you
didn't trim very well. They're standing beside or
something. So there's a few things around
there and because we were trimming so regularly last week,
so several spinners wing, we measured 3 times in the
competition and we were finding his trim was coming out
identical each day. Within one millimetre the trim
was coming out the same. However, the actual line
lengths, how far away the wing was, was varying by up to 15
millimetres daily, literally going further away or coming
closer. But luckily the trim is staying
the same. The manufacturer's obviously
done the maths right on the line thicknesses versus the loads,
the trim state and so so trimming is repetitive.
You can do it and rely on the settings in the rules.
So Ted, building the fast is the limit.
Slow, you go as slow as you like.
That's not to say it's safe. If your wing is 10 millimetres
slow, retrim it. It's the reason it's like that
and the rules is that they don't believe you're cheating.
Doesn't mean it's safe, you're just not cheating on trying to
fly too fast. Daily performance, that's what
the rules are about. So how often to actually trim a
wing? Will I know some top pilots that
trim for every comp and look at the venue they're going to and
they so if you go to Columbia on a week year, he'll trim it his
wing about one or two mil fast. If he then goes to Slovenia
where it's all Ridge running, he'll trim it to 10 mil fast
because he wants a much faster wing and sink rates not
important in the week and he wants a slower wing crimes
better. So the top pilots trim to the
venue, going to the conditions and the day.
The average pilot it probably come more down to how was your
wing tougher for the last few weeks or months.
If you go to a damp environment, then to A to A, to a cold damp
or cold, cold, dry and then a hot, humid environment, your
wings will change hugely in the space of a day or two.
So that's definitely when I'd look to retrim.
So if I'm going from the French house to Colombia, real Ruchevo,
I would definitely want to do a few flights in Ruchevo and then
check my trim and it will changed or as I had in Jamuna on
the PwC a few weeks ago, I flew I had a brand new when you
delivered to me by gym of new bloom rang.
It flew beautifully on the practice.
If you flew beautiful in the first task and then I flew flew
through some rain, I dried it out.
I flew the next day and it was falling out of the air
completely with sort of two days.
I struggled flying it. I checked the trim on how to
speed it up by 10 mil. I had to release the bee loops
on the wind with just two hours airtime and that got it back to
flying an ice and that was just a less than a minute of a bit of
rain. Completely made the wing
dangerous and it wouldn't stretch back out to flyable.
I had to just change the lines. So how often really for the
average pilot it's more about what conditions you've been
flying in recently and if it might have affected you in.
If it feels nice, just keep flying it, but if it feels a bit
strange then I'll have to stop there, check it and adjust it
when I fly. The sorts of things I look for.
When I hit a thermal straight on, does the wing pull forward
and want to go into it? That's what I want to bite.
You lift me up in it. Or does it get knocked back with
tiny bear and then I have to force it into thermal?
It's too slow, it gets knocked back, so you need to accelerate
it to bite into thermi. And then the other one you can
look at is when it's biting into thermals, if you dare.
Hands off everything, no speed bar everything, hands off to
trim. And does it bite symmetrical?
Or do the wing tips here one with it?
Or do the wing tips accelerate? If they accelerate, the tips are
too fast, they get knocked back, tips are too slow.
And it's not that you alter the tips necessarily, you might
alter the centre, but that's just a very easy indication that
it is my wing. Nice tips, go back.
The tips go forward. We can go back or we can go
forward. It tells you everything you need
for the trimming, tiny little exercise.
And therefore it's not about the numbers you see on the screen,
the numbers on the screen when you're trimming them.
It's what other people have got. But it's not just the lines that
vary. The sale varies the fastest,
vary lots of other things, and will change.
But those other things you can't alter if you sail.
If the material shrieks, well, the stitching stretches.
In theory, it's pretty hard to measure, but in theory, the old
your wing is the higher aspect of his.
There's all those stitching on all the cells.
If every bit stitching stretches half a millimetre with time on
100 cells, it's actually goes stretching in both directions,
1/2 middle. You will invite your 20
centimetres higher aspect as it gets older.
You can't change that. That's how it is your plastics,
they tend to absorb humidity and they can change the length of
them and particularly I mean on the high end, they're very
sensitive to the length of the plastics.
They can make it really aggressive when they expand all
the material we should use gives the impression past it's
expanded. But again, it's pretty hard to
know how to correct rats. You can cut the plastics if you
know what you're doing, but that's a bit of a new steel.
People are learning and you can't measure it.
It's a judgement call. But those things you don't try
and shouldn't help with trimming, it's fine.
Ice again, which is why you can't rely on he's got 753 on
his trim, so argue 753 now. How old is his wing?
What environment does it flow in?
So the fact is so it always comes back down to I'm enjoying
my wing. Yes, leave it LA, don't mess
with the trim. But if it's hanging back, I go
forwards play with some trimming.
So that's a bit on those things you need, well, obviously the
trimmer and the several sorts out there.
I'm going to try and design one this winter that when you pull
the line, the backboard will retain to automatically and have
a curve in it to allow for offsets.
So that that under attempt to do, you've got there's loads of
other brands out there you can use.
The best 1 is a manufacturer's type of professional 1 where
it's on sliding rails and it guarantees you hit the exactly
centre 90° and that's well, it doesn't actually complicate you.
That's enough lasers. You're going to have to spend a
bit of money on the laser more than the trimmer get the disto
ones tend to be the best round out there because they're into
to a laptop so you can do it all on your own.
Otherwise these cheap lasers, they'll need someone to help you
call out the numbers tiger into the spreadsheet and you're going
to expect should we spend a bit of money on the laser in the
Dead Space? Obviously.
And then you need the software and you can use Excel
spreadsheets. Most manufacturers will supply
them, but the there's a website I can send them linked out later
as a website we measure and they've got pretty much every
wing on the market in there. And it really is as simple as
just and a wing. If this is going to work, talk
about the wallets. I mean don't target Yeah, I need
some IT help, but I don't know how this too we like to Oh, it's
very better. What size is that bounce of
medium? That's what that is.
MSMSMS, that's how. Genuine do.
That yeah, tell it what wing you've got and then you tell it
loose they're already in. So this particular wing I know
is not no loops anywhere. I'll talk about loops in a
moment. When you when you receive your
wing almost certainly has a loop in the EBUR rises and it's there
because your wing will change a lot in the 1st 30 hours might do
rang 2 hours, some wings 100 hours birds 3 hours is a rough
guess and then you'd release them to allow for change.
How fast Sunday TV is that on that one See you laser which is
Moxford slaw. What they do now is they just
basically show us the wing which is looking down at it and you
just take all the measurements that you automate is obviously
he's got pinotin per inch or so go right.
What are we doing that in the background?
I think that's the xeno one. It is the xeno one.
Just look at the IT was that's the one option was 2017.
Obviously he wants. What it was what about let me
out. You're out.
Let me. There you go.
It was I don't give me a walk. So you know 2 Ms. asked which to
handle will trim. That's you.
You think you're a 01 son was here too.
Oh. That's why.
See, I've used this website before.
Wait, there we go. So we collect that again.
So you don't bother with the officer on the offsets.
Irrelevant. Yeah, completely relevant
because we're just not the angle attack.
The the after error then angle will also be relevant, but this
as much. Longer, yeah, because it's not
calculation angles with I think. That's what I mean, like you're
always and it's centimeters off to the left and it will be the
same on the launch. Yeah, exactly.
Yeah. So yeah, we don't worry about
that at all. Let's what?
Do I miss it? Just touch it again.
Start. Did you left the corner on the
knob or from the bottom? So you should measure from the
cloth. So that's holding the laser
against the cloth where the knot is.
We don't because the disto has got a nice little slot in it and
you can just put it on the line and slide it against the knot.
If you don't understand that you can have it.
So theoretically some error Depends on how good the
manufacturer is it making every type the same length.
Now I assume they make them all the same length because we're
doing averaging. So on Group One depends on the
wing, but so on the Enzo and group round, there's 12 lines on
well Group 2 site Route 2 to the 12 lines that I've memorized and
there saw four other in the tapes divided or averaged over
the 12. So it should be irrelevant
really not, not as important. You'd go most, of course.
Let's do it backwards. It's still sort of standardized
to me. It's what?
Sorry. It's like sort of standardized
to me. Yeah, you have to know that,
right? Yeah.
So 5 kilos on the back. It's important to use 5 kilos if
you're in a competition. Your own stir.
We've done some testing about 2 kilos to 8 kilos.
Once the line's gone stable, it's doesn't really vary.
You can have a quite a large tolerance, but just for your own
general trimming 456 kilos, whatever you can get is OK.
But if you are in a super high level comp and you're wanting to
push the minutes a bit, you better use 5 kilos the same as
the the organisers do to make sure you don't have any problems
there. Yeah.
Other than that, Fury by Fiat, you'll get another.
It's according to quite a. Bit it's like it's very, yeah,
yeah. It's only the connect connects.
So I've got too much going on here.
Microphone, microphone, the microphone works.
That's good to come here now. Whoops.
Up last means she made a mistake.
Yes, can. You hear me?
Yes. So I was wondering the yes, you
mentioned that we spend money on the laser, isn't only the
connection to the laptop or something else?
That's just the correction. So if that's the case, my rotor
program for myself to connect almost any laser by being only
rotocol with what they will let me know if people are interested
so I can establish that program. So I've been up in this, yeah.
Yeah, do that, Yeah. I mean the expensive one is
because we measure supports it or it's easy for most laptops.
But yeah, if there's other brands and other programs, we
measure just one of many, it's the one I prefer.
I could try this. Is that better for anybody or it
is this doubt? What else is there?
Not truly anybody. Questions.
Not truly. Yeah, I will know what should
go. You mentioned that I would
prefer fly wings. 3A little differently than the
manufacturers suggests. Why?
I mean, why manufacturers would suggest something different than
the best three? OK.
The manufacturers designed it. Design process is quite
complicated and a lot of it depends on the manufacturer as
well. So Enzo from a particularly rich
manufacturing company, they put a lot of time and effort in
supplying and they get, you know, spend a lot of prototypes
and they went completely nice before they release.
So probably when they say 0000 they they mean that's a pretty
good trend. Pilots want to win comps, they
want to go faster so they accelerate it.
And so 7 mil vast of the centres are pretty sweet spot.
Gin, I'm working with Gin quite a lot.
So he's delivering to the blue rings quite regularly to try.
He delivers them on the first task.
He throws me into the cop. I haven't even got a clue what
trim it is. But because he's having to
certify that because he's legal in the cop, he's, he's deciding
it, he's making it, he's sending it, he's having a plight sending
it to a certain occasion in the house.
They take the measurements and record that as a legal true,
send it to me. I fly it and go, no, it's too
slow or too fast. It must be even harder for small
manufacturers. Jim's still got a reasonable set
up. So you would hope those at the
Fortune releases, it will even do a lot more testing than
research by the credit companies.
But it is just a guest by the manufacturers.
And as I say, the whole thing's based around and winked.
But out it is whoops, gone again 10 years during sign out other
brands it's going to be harder. So don't focus on the numbers
too much. Just focus on it being less than
10 and feels nice on W's cushion button for him.
She had a beak. The beats to say that the
reading is completely wrong. It's way too.
This is trimming in the wild, right?
She's trimming. She's trimming.
The left side was the upper right.
You're looking down on the wind, the spot where every software is
looking away. What are the questions?
I begin. Can you still where exactly put
the leather there you go. Yeah.
I don't know if Max to hold up brilliant show as much as the
next one when she's found the right line.
It depends on your laser machine, but this one's got a
nice little cut out on the back and you just click in on the
line against the take would not the against the materials
better, but she puts it against the knot instead, so it's
slightly wrong that's. What about like when you you
know, lines that are like geology, but they're upon honest
men's bastard and. How do you know over?
The deadly mind whether it's if you use.
Flu. It would be a Macedonian example
for me. Macedonia every day for the rest
of your life. Your glider probably won't
change. Trim that because it's the same
dry weather every day. It's humidity is your biggest
enemy. So the bricks have a hard time.
In the UK that breaks down here was in the morning and evening
and quite dry in the middle of the day.
So just the time of day changes your way.
That's the first problem. But the other problem is when
you buy it in, the lines have never been loaded and they would
change over the next 20 or 30 hours.
But actually it's not the lines that your biggest problem, it's
for knots. So wherever the cascades split
from 1:00 to 2:00, it's the knot that is the problem.
Manufacturers very tighten it so much and then when you start
flying, your aid lines are loaded with maybe 20 kilos per
line up front and centre. So that knot getting really
tight vibration, the lending, the 2G's, when you do turns, it
tightens a knot and it can extend the lines by 10 mil quite
fast. Your B's, which we're testing at
5 kilos when you're flying on full bar, which is where Oz guys
are a lot of time, they've only got one or two kilos in reality.
So when you're trimming, you're stretching your B's and then
they re shrink. In flights when we're shriveling
the A's, we don't stretch them at all that we should know, but
in flight we strike them a lot. So these are 20 hours to get
them off sale and everything in the sweet spot.
That makes sense. If the wing doesn't bite into
the thermal, what increments do you so the wings are fighting
into the filler? I would just first just the
people trim and I would say it's definitely negative.
It's probably negative by about 10 mil.
So just speed it up by 10 bill to 8 to 0.
But I don't those numbers are talking about We'll see it on
the end. Yes, you still Mike.
It's a great one more lot when you buy the mince and almost on
the slope. So when you buy the new wing, it
should be set to roughly 0 thereabouts, but bees or the bee
rises will have a loop on the lights at the top and they the
manufacturer knows that it will change approximately 10 bill
after approximately 20 to 30 hours.
And then you release those bees to restore it back to zero.
That's the theory, but it depends on all those other
factors. So you're shaking it rather than
just reducing it. 30 hours is a far better way I don't know
about. The the mint it comes. 10
millimetres faster when you buy it new than the specification.
That's also true. Actually the when it's delivered
it's probably not at 0. Actually the first inflation
that's probably 10 or 15 mil fast and just in the first
minutes it will start slowing down and then after a few hours
it goes towards zero and then after many hours it goes to
slow. And it's probably, I'm guessing
a little bit of all of these things.
It's probably towards 100 hours before your wing is totally
stable, and even trust that it should won't change a long time.
Do you recommend doing like 2 right like gentle spirals on
each side to even out and ox? I mean, you get what?
Are you doing what I do when I find a new wing?
I do spiral it left and right quickly, but that's because
should each give me a wing on the first task that I've got to
get this wing settled in minutes.
But when you've got a settled wing, never spiral.
The worst thing you can do to attune the competition wing is
spiraling. When you arrive at goal, do not
spiral your wing down. It will ruin that trimmed
seconds to the point that it's Asia electric and when you're on
full bar, you know, hanging on 1B to make stride, apply the
straight line. It's just destroying the speed.
So don't spiral them, but I do spiral them myself to try and
accelerate the tightening of knots anymore you're worrying
about. Any of attack.
Well, about anyone and V there's nothing you don't.
There's no issues around us. It's shaping.
OK. So that's change of the article
with that's the releasing BS versus 2 of the LS.
So the manufacturers allow you to release the B to lead for the
B lines to to accelerate it. But when you talk to the
designers, they don't like doing that.
I'd prefer to this does actually work because it's stretchy.
They like to lift the A's instead of when you're releasing
B. If you're only released to B on
the centre, it does increase the arc.
We're at centre point at the back, whereas if you tighten it
on the A's because it's the A's that stretch really it it does
also the entire wing show the average sports wing.
I wouldn't worry too much, but when you're getting on to the
CCC level, that sort of thing can come into play.
Everyone, what about smaller distance?
What's the equivalent of that as well?
OK, so like you are 80% of people in this room, you just do
10 mil jumps while altering the lines of the manuals to release
single looping this programme. Again, what we get there is very
good at being able to make smaller changes, but if you
really want to trim a wig, you need to be looking at two or
three millimetre changes. So that applies to 10% of these
root baby that want to get their week to perfection for that.
Now we do line inserts. So all these Hevlar lines are
actually hollow. They're tubes.
And if you push the line together, you'll see it opens up
the tube. And if you get some needles, you
can put some line inside the tube to make it fatter and that
shortens the entire line length. And that's how we do the teeth
held. Trimming on these things, doing
that. So there's there's just
different ways to do it. You can measure your line
measure on the trimmer, you can see you need to alter it by two
millimetres. Shortening it.
You put a line in sort of in the two mil.
You re measure it on the trimmer.
But when you re measure it on the trimmer, you probably find
it's the same length even though you just shortened it 2 mil.
Because the trouble is when you when you pull this the first
time, it stretches out to whatever natural length it wants
to be. The second time you do it, it
stretches a tiny big wall. The third time it might stretch
a tiny bit more. Then it goes quite stable after
that. So if you shorten it to mil, you
then measure it. It's the same length as you
stretch it to mil. You end up chasing yourself with
it a little bit. So why don't we just pull three
times? I don't measure well, the
manufacturer doesn't do that of the person neither the office
who's enforcing the rules doesn't do that.
You have to do it the same way they do it.
So you should do everything with one pull and then if you need to
alter by two bill, there's a trick on this particular
trimmer. There's actually a tape measure
on the trimmer there. Mark Tandler wants millimeter
input and it'll often if you push the button it pops out the
drawl where you lock the needles stored in the line.
And what you do is you put 2 needles into the lolly, you
measure how far apart they are, you quit your insert between
them and then you measure how far apart they are.
When it's 2mm less change is done.
You don't need to re measure. It's faster and it's more
accurate and it glides all with the rules and how they're
enforced. That's the makes sense.
You can go and see afterward. Max has to do it, which you're
obvious to do it you're finished who?
Any any particular reason for alignment serves towards
gallery? Looks going to gallery looks as
well, but a gallery you you have to know how much it'll change
it, which is what if the light that this this it will be
several hours before that fully times, whereas it's certainly to
yeah. So to me, I prefer it to this.
Let's see what a wing is. You see how good or bad it is
optimal cans to do this, but we're reading here, but they go
on that. So on here you can see this is
the a wall. So a cake riser at one is the
centrally on that sterilite and it's set for no loops at the
moment. This is the B behind it and E2B2
and so on. And her trim is currently on the
centre 6 mil fast, cent hill fast.
That's the sweet spot I was talking about before the Zeno's
very simple. The endo.
The next ones out should be a little bit slower.
So one mil and five mil. That would suggest you put a bit
of a turn to the left. Of this way and.
Then the tips, 4 mil and three mil, tiny bit faster to leave,
but they're OK. So the trim actually is quite
nice on that wing. It's not really much to change,
but if I wanted to, for example, slow down this left tip, what I
could do is just, well, there's no loop here.
I could put a loop on and it says it'll be fine, more slow.
If I did that, it's an instant what Y wing look like.
If I start pressing footings when I'm happy, I can apply it.
What if I also speed it up that one it goes back to where it
was. What I do it could play around
with different ideas. So if I put one loop there and
two loops here, last one here, so do one nil fast nicer trim
sounds good. But in reality I'm actually
changing the shape shape of the what's this in reality of the
reality of changing the shape of the wing.
If I do too many loops I'm pulling that section down, which
makes funny shapes. So you can rather be careful
with some of this for two or three mil changes.
I prefer to do that with inserts and most wings based on an Enzo
Xeno. Those types of wings you're
looking for a centre to be at good speed, a nice angle of
attack, 5 mil, the next one a bit slower, the tips slower
still. That's ozone wings.
The boomerangs are similar, the Nivea FX 1 completely different,
totally different. So don't just apply that sort of
knowledge to different brands. And X1, if it's faster than 0
mil it's probably a hell of a handful and not very nice.
And the sweet spot on them seems to be flying it a couple of
millimetres slow on the manufacturer said so they tell
me I've got the X1, but any trim I see on X1 is usually a
negative figures not fast. So again, does it fly nice to
focus on the numbers too much? We're comparing nails in the
middle and the outside as well. We after I guess the cord is
shorter, so 3 nails in the outside is more than 806 nails
instead of. Yeah, it's yeah.
The only the distance is changed towards the tip, so these
acceleration figures have more effect towards the tip.
Why are you slowing everything? Well, it's in.
Any more bits on trilling? I thought I'd do 30 minutes.
We've been here an hour. Perfect.
The the inserts? Yeah.
Where do you place them? Along the the line.
Of course the. Riser, so if you do inserts or
if you push so we'll get a piece of hold up if on this a line.
If I just push it together, it hollows out.
We'll see a tube if I put another an old is line inside to
fab. It's that what shortens it.
I would use the place stubs maybe 30 centilitres from the
riser to near the bottom. I don't put it right up against
it because it's already it's already got lines, certainly
line. And you make bending points if
you put it next to edge or you bend the others in the same
place And Kevlar Will's fracture and great bench here.
So one of the spread those places when you put the insert
in, some people leave a bit sticking out so that maybe for
example, you've got it wrong, you can remove it later and redo
it or something like that. That's fine for free flying.
If your insert is renewable in a competition, that's the penalty
0 for the day. That's to stop cheating.
So you for example, it's might happen occasionally in a super
final recently, someone will lands with a very aggressive
trim and then you'll just grab those little loops and pull them
all out on the ground and then his wings taken away from
Vegemite. So if it's removable, it's
considered cheating, even though he'd then not remove it.
So what's he had more? Rockets in the Macedonian
outlaws. Singapore.
Macedonia had monothacks? No, I'm not aware of that.
Having hanged up did Macedonia for the Europeans.
But yeah, if it's removable, it's super.
Plano Riado 11 pilot who did it not league European champion
yeah, yeah, there was one guy who but they still got him and.
Then the other part is anything, any changes to your wings
whatsoever that's going to affect the speed in flights or
respects affect the speed system is a modification.
It's not allowed. The only exception to that, but
so is if you you may have seen people putting bits of plastic
in by pulleys. So on the on on your speed
system, you've got pulleys over time a bit webbing can stretch
and that it's hard as to get full bar as when you put the
speed push the speed bar, you can overlap them, but you can't
allow for the stretch on it. So some people put pencils or
bits of plastic in behind here just to probably pull you back.
That's OK. You're allowed to do that
because the thing that stops you flying any faster than tenders
was that the weather there to an A&B and of course, insistence
that wedding goes tight and then you cannot go any faster than
intended. So changes to quality system is
OK and that's the reason the SRS and the CSC bands wings don't
have that tape, that tape really easy to go to there and they
keep pulling, pulling your feet and go further and further
further. So that is mandatory in the SRS
and the CSC goblets. Have that only for wings here
2012 quarter the. SRS Any wing made after 2020 or.
1st January. Yeah and the CSC every wing OK
and the manufacturers have don't do it, don't add it.
Usually manufacturers never made ACCC win before because they
always did in the CCC documentation every team owners
should have that work in day one.
So it's only new manufacturers that tend to miss if the
manufacturers didn't break CCC and there's any specific.
Any specific reason why we got down from 18 to 10?
Like almost. The because only let's say
faction pilots have the skills to have living that faster it
blows out. It's not fair on their mortals
like me. That's the particular there
fairness in competitions. OK.
And another one is sorry, just just just one last, is there a
limit? After which the.
Ring is not stable like 2025 because I think Luke mentioned
CM number. Yeah, that comes down to the
wing. Every wing is different.
I mean, it gets to a point where your bees have no pressure.
So we've had already have sports wings in the SRS where when you
accelerate too far, the bees became floppy.
It just had no effect. You've got no direct control of
your wing now at full bar. You just have to wait for the
block to feel it coming. Yeah, I'm sure there's lots of
variations on that. There's various entirely on the
wind design. Various entirely on the wind
design. Almost pitching more.
Want to Indesign to the wing? But I'm not expression it.
Tips are a bit fast, I was that effect were maintained very.
In term, if your wings are tips are too fast in terms of
performance, your wing has its best performance when the whole
thing was exactly the same angle of attack that's given it the
best the the east frontal area if you like for performance.
So yeah, if it's not quite right, you're going to have
extra drag or, but as two accelerated or two slow, it's
going to be extra drag at tips. But that's not easy to design in
because distance A&B Route 1 is different to route 2 is
different. Route 3, well, you've only got 1
speed bar, so they have to do clever things.
And on your, your Steve system with the pulleys with a three to
one ratio and full 12 centimetres shortens this bit by
4, but on the tips. And again, there's different,
different wings. So I'm just on this one in
particular. The tip actually is on a
separate Dyneema line and that has 2 to one ratio.
In addition, except for the last tiny bits, this little, this
line has now got a one to one ratio.
So the wing tips usually have very clever little designs in
the riser system to try and keep it going.
It's same how as a centre. Otherwise the centre changed by
10 centimetre. The tips properly change at 20
plus centimetres, if that makes sense.
Not a perfect way to swagger here, but it's just it's closer.
So it's faster. Yeah, reduce the acceleration.
So if I answer any questions, what else do we got on the 10
millimetres here? Now you're looking at the
average. It's super also or so it's going
down to detail. So in CCC, which is all we had
last year, it's all describing there and it was a 20 millimetre
limit at that time. But you average and it's all
about these figures. So this is your A1, you talk
about a one everything you're taxed at the top of that, it's
averaged. And then on your B1, everything
on the top of that is average. So then you're comparing this
one to this one at your bottom. That makes sense.
You see you're averaging 12 lines on that one and to
whatever it is. And then that, I don't know how
many it is probably 12:00-ish again.
But then you could do like 15,000,000 was fast on the
middle of the edge. OK, So for that sense though,
when you say 10 mil limit, each group has a 10 mil limit.
You can't go 1510 far. You can say it's 10:15 on was
was breaking the rules already, even if the others are slow.
Each group was a limit 10. Inside each group will average
out the line because multiple just move around a bit to equal
them on the way to having each line.
A single line could be up to 5 centimeters well as long as that
entire group then comes out and sees it corrects Yeah, but Cane
wouldn't there for his allowance if you could unbox into lines
and stuff right Yeah yeah talking about is different in
the aid yes yeah, it'll be a good.
And then after a while they have seen they explain it as much as
it has the 1st come over speedy. Yeah, yeah, are.
You if other to be we that you are.
Yeah, at trillions like the weather, there's lots of
variations, there's lots of brands, there's lots of
different things going on. And we're trying to make one
rule after everything, which is also difficult.
And the next problem we will have in three or four years, all
of this will have to change again because again, I'll pick
on ozone. There's just no particular
reason I'll pick on ozone. It'd be any manufacturer for the
end zone 4. The next wing that's will come
eventually all the manufacturer has to do when he released it is
say well, this is a nice wing that's accelerated 5 mil
certifier, put it back to our new zero and sell that.
And then that allows the manufacturers that so the pilots
then have a 15 nil stoke. So the 10 and they've already
got it on the X1. We know the sweet spot is about
1/2 nil Sloan, whereas the sweet spot on Enzo 7 Nils fast.
So X1 pilots already can go far faster than mere mortals can
handle like me. So this whole game is constantly
FAI or City. I'd be our set of rules.
And then the sport develops and then we see what pilots or
manufacturers do and we have to make a new rule.
I don't know how it'd be tackled in three or four years, but for
sure this rule only works this year and next year.
And then clever ways will be found to gain speed other ways.
We already found some creative ones last week with Europeans
from pilots which are we're eradicate the best we can.
Don't like talking about them publicly too much because most
of you don't know these trips and it's a hell of a lot of work
Island some of them. How much did they invade?
100K task, but 90 KS. You probably want to think truth
is slow. It was that unto carries.
It's about getting there, climbing and just being able to
keep up with the league gaggle. The last 10 of that is the first
who's signed it. It's the first man to come off
so long. So when you all go, that's the
end of our third league first goal.
Let's go the fastest man who's lost the line 1st and Clive will
be faster on your spin. It is to 15 millimetres more
speed path effectively named which on depends on the level of
being on sports wings, it's probably not worth much.
One or two pair of H with one or two pair of H on 10 kilometres.
That could be a hell of a lot of seconds in front.
It's a huge gain on an Enzo boomerang.
That is the difference between fashion and the task or being
30th but they will this game they will ask save you that's
folks do a sleek the hardest is to do we apply them awful does
it makes difference of sleeve got such bigger numbers as just
adding $10 machine and in all the finals also is still even
topic a little bit not real for the chin, but now for one to be
distant. There are guys were the after
one year. You must have a revision of the
so documentation for trim tests. If we do it alone what's
happened That's OK. So what should you have a test
house do these or can you do it yourself?
That's actually down to the country you're from or the
country you're in on what their rules are.
There is nothing at the sport, not even DHV have anything that
mandates who can test a wing. There is Carol often to test it.
So I I don't know, but probably the manual I never read says
every year or every two years or something.
But there's no such thing as an food test house for trim
checking. So in Slovenia, if your wing is,
I can't remember the numbers now, if your wing is more than
two years old, was it? It must be checked within 12
months and you need documentation to prove it.
So when we take the SRS to Slovenia, you all have to give
evidence. And the CAA guy did turn up at
task one and check. Actually it's quite funny
because he went to the local Overbeats airport to understand
why we weren't there. So he just said the passion of
aragliding we're over the other side valley.
But when he found us, he checked make sure we had the
documentation. He doesn't understand that he's
checking. But for many of you guys message
privately. It's just for that Excel sheet
and just to a quick check and show that you did the trim shed
you got evidence you did it just matter who did it to itself.
But it is really down to the law in your country or flying or
north from or something. So all manufacturer they open
mandate how often and he was. So yeah, let's move to Wake and
Palace. That was your line.
So Wake and Palace, I did. I've got some members of what it
is now. I think we're on the fly a
little bit. But for next year there are
changes to Wakewood is on equipment.
We used to have these in the squats years ago, that your
equipment was only allowed to weigh 33 kilos.
Balas, wing, drinking water, everything.
Well, we moved away from it for several reasons.
One, it's a lot of work for the organiser to enforce this.
Two, it's easy to cheat. Three, it just wasn't fair to
some people. So Magdalena for example, that
Brazil last year, it's going to see 25 kilos of Alice trying to
get a win, looks competitive because the extra small win,
it's just got zero chance in a race like that.
So that's unfair. The PwC years gone by, you used
to stand on the scales at registration and then if you
have checked any point in the comp, you should be within 33
kilos of that weight at registration.
But people get ill in comps, for example, or dehydrated, their
weight changes. It doesn't mean their kit has
changed weight, just them they have changed weight.
If you can deal last night, whatever, or you just put 5
kilos of less in your knit This no one's gonna ask to drop your
packs at registration. We're just trusting at your
weights. You just stay into 5K advantage
for the rest of the competition. So it was ways of abusing.
It was difficult to handle. However, the score is going back
to the way she is and it's mandatory for all competitions,
not just category one from next year.
But they've done it slightly different.
If your win is 95 kilos or less on certification, you'll have as
much weight as you like. That's to help people like
Magdalena stay competitive. Yeah, yeah, absolutely. 500
wings than it. But if, if she weighs that all
her wife is these days 50 kilos. She can carry 4 and 5 kilos to
get what she wants. Applies a 95K wing.
Really, if you're flying 100K wings, you're only allowed 33
kilos of equipments and drinking water and everything else.
There's a little bit of a dig of people.
So that's a bit of a pain, you know, to start finding ways of
measuring you lot. Again, it's to compromise to
help the small people stay capacitive.
But they threw one extra thing because a lot of this comes down
to the manufacturers not giving small people ice wings and
that's down to money mainly. I think Bruce says that's what
it is. Russell Ogden said on the extra
extra stall or whatever extra stall Enzo, they sold rim as I'm
not a certification cost of three people.
So they've got 0 incentive to do this.
So what they tend to do is just wait, load test the biggest wing
and they use that thickness line all the smaller.
It's just nice cheek wear a certify, but a small person has
got leather fit lungs relative to their size of white.
But I really that's the problem. So what Sir has been thrown in
is from next year it was a 95K world Shank gear.
Now there's a proper world title at stake.
Now there's an incentive for the manufacturers that work a bit
more on small wings, but there's also an incentive for anyone
100K wing just to do whatever you do.
So fly a minus of 5K wing now. And so instead of flying 100
against someone on 130K wing and losing performance, you can just
go down a tiny bit. You're not going to beat him
still. But now you've got a well signed
it, you can aim for it stairs. So hopefully that's enough of a
carrot to encourage the manufacturers to develop these
smaller ones better. So we'll see 2000 time for 15
minutes on that off, let's say the other bits on weight.
I don't know how strict will get on the SRS, but I don't think
it's a huge issue. You get actually even in
Europeans last week, abusing weight limits is not an issue.
So Sebastina, one of the top pilots in the world on the
British team, he likes to fly lights on his 115 Enzo.
He regularly flies 110 kilos, 108 kilos, and he's known for
just climbing amazingly fast and then staying with you.
He tried going to 115 and 1000 Europeans couldn't climb at all.
Went back to 113. It was if you can't climb,
you're not with the needs anyway, so weight's not a big
issue. The most pilot only for the very
little people. I'll cover it, hey or wait so.
You were saying it's to 95 like say for example like the Xenon
Ms. goes to 100. Yeah.
If I fly it at 94, would that be counted or not?
No. So same rules, the SRS, it's
certification that counts, not the weight you actually fly it
at. Otherwise we'd have to weigh you
every day and when you land you're probably a kilo to, low
to and then to talk. So it's certification, it's all
about that. OK, I'm not even recommended.
So we had one wing earlier this year, it was certified to 101
but recommended 99 to a lot of pilots flew it in mid weight
class and we've realized afterwards no certification else
it's the ease of check quarters. There's this new category
they're clocking in a granny diet and below and you're you've
been sending a code in with that.
That's excellent. No, no, you're all flying in the
overalls no matter what. When it comes to points.
There's quotes to do with W press and mock to do with
competition itself. And you don't have the branch.
I wouldn't say that. So yeah.
And obviously 95 is what the sport uses.
I believe it was the British had brought it in 14 years ago
called Red Oaks class when I spread through the sport and the
95 was based on APWC stroke. CCC ruled A manufacturer had to
make a 95K win in CCC. So that's why it's chosen Bruce
L Smith, who's who's here still, but he's he was running BGD
weightless. I've worked within the first
five years and we tried weight passes on the 1st opposition and
I that worked really well to ask, but for me we're supposed
to find better ways. But that's why in the SRS, we
adopted 8 and 5 and 100 and the 85 on the first year captured
40% of the pilots. 100 that's cracked captured 40% actually,
sorry, 30% and 30% then and then to rest.
The other 40% were all heavier people in acts of fat.
When we look at that now, there are not very many in the
lightweight class now compared to the start.
So either they can't keep up still and they've given up or
they're paring ballast. There's the paring ballast.
So they're leaving the Midway and the Midway people are moving
up to the overall. But at the moment I'll stick
with those numbers. At the moment Tesla Fiatus mine
was numbers here rather than. Yeah, 100 kilos or below of.
The up in that our president. Yeah, yeah.
But the SRS is not CIBL. So most of Section 7 is about
category one competitions, World Championships, Optetzel, the
SRS. It's only of it's.
Yeah, yeah, it's, it's 100 -, 100 CIBL for me.
CIBL, there's the 95K champion, the SRS, we have a A5 champion
and 100 champion. We might hold to him in future,
but at the moment we haven't changed so.
It was nice to fight in Colombia.
No, it was 100. The trophy was misprinted.
No, you say club, you had a trophy printed wrong.
We didn't play into the organiser after you actually
said bit weight. I think for the lightweight and
the bit weight. Sort of really starts, but maybe
maybe I'm confusing the different comps.
Well, it could be other costs, yeah, yeah.
I think it would be unfair to all pilots and not track traffic
ones, especially central. We might change it in future,
but if we change it, I will always change it so that there
is a significant number of pilots in each class.
The last one we want is adapting our lug weight to 92.
No sorry, the mid weight to night and fire and seeing just a
few pilots in it. So I'll think the class is to be
essential number in each one. Make it a competition.
Any more on that or should we move on to that?
The other one it's worth covering or the other two bits
I'll cover quickly is so next year, for those that haven't
heard, we will have the first World Sports Final, which is an
SRS event. So that's the Super final of
sports. But I'll try not to use the word
super final. Just avoid diffusing everybody.
So it's the World Sports Trophy, so it will be in July in Jomona.
It's not open registration. You can only go to it if you
qualify for it from this season. And the I've mentioned this for
a while now, but just you guys. So to get to it, the top 10
pilots from each SRS event to qualify into it.
So whoever comes in the top 10 this week is allowed with
isolated top three ladies, the COP 3 lightweights, the top
three mid weights pilots say from every event to run this
year. And often of course that would
be the seller PD. So it's not that most of the
places have now gone, it's often the same people that I'll
probably fill up. I haven't done the maths yet,
but 40 or 50 placed it maximum. And then for all of the other
places we offer them according to your ranking at the end of
the season. So after Mexico, we'll calculate
the season ranking and then whoever's first will get offered
a place. Or you can already block one up.
Sure be winning an event and then we just go down the list.
So if you're in the top 100, you're probably going to get an
offer. It probably hasn't turned us
down. Then probably go down to 150th
maybe and after that we'll just race as a one off.
It's in next year's season in calendar year July.
But it has nothing to do with the season ranking next year.
So next year there'll be 4 SRS events to make the season
ranking next year and there'll be a separate world sports final
which will not review points since next year's season.
It's a one off competition. It's not partnered with any of
our partners. It's just the world sports
filing, not the Ozone edition or BGD which and I was ever fly off
and see who's the best. Basically I've got the dates
somewhere second or third we could do rather something.
So yeah, see what you do this week, then see if you qualify
for a place. Second please. 4 is excellent,
but we got gymnastics but I forget all the dates.
We'll be set the dates a while ago, but we already used
calendar to avoid, so we should be correct.
So that's that one. And then the other people that
would qualify the legends. So that's the people who won a
season or won a previous sports. I don't know if you haven't had
one yet. So for example, Powell Tacketts
won last year, so he gets a place every year forever more.
And the top lady as well. So there's 2 legend each year.
Infuriated. I mean, go back to the start of
the Ross Rs. They all get access forever into
the series. We get more of those as we go.
So that's that one. And then the last one, which you
should you all read the rules. Every competition you read the
rules. Yeah, this new CSC thing, which
is something you really have to have in mind going forwards.
So CSC, it's the CIVL sports optician win.
There's a definition of what you're allowed to fly in the
category one in the future and is recommended into category 2
as well. And the SRS will be adopted
here. So I I was leading the CIVL work
group for this along with Cuba here Thomas.
It had input from might be about 10 or 12 manufacturers and their
surveys went out to you all and stuff.
And then from that it was approved what this CSC
definition will be. And so from years from 2028, it
had been Matt and Tree will win was either certified last year
or before, or it falls into this new definition.
So your photons, your Ttos, your cure threes, you're going to fly
theoretically forever in a category one in the SRS as long
as you like. It's it's legal.
But anyway, certified after the 1st of May this year.
You could fly it this season, you could fly it next season,
but the year after that, in 2028, if it doesn't comply with
the CSC definition, it's now bad.
So you better be very careful what wings you buy for this
year. Next year.
It must have a speed limiter. We've always had that rule.
The aspect ratio must be 6.8 or less for the flat.
It must have 67 cells or less and it must the weight, the
weight won't be an issue. The weight must be 10% or less
of the certified. So there's a hundred from the
wing. The wing's only allowed to weigh
10 kilos, mostly 5 or 6 kilos in these days, So that's fine.
There's a lot of reasons why all that was developed in CIVL and
the SRS has helped inform them. They might be they're a little
bit stricter than they might have wanted, but there's reasons
for it. For example, the Zeno here on
the floor, if you looked at the certification on this Zeno, it's
actually an it complies as an ENC if it's created for
certification today, it's an ENC.
It only got D because it's needed folding lines and in that
year folding lines were banned in ENC.
Now they're allowed that mean would be an ENC certified today,
but is probably beyond the utilities of quite a few of you
in the room to fly it. And it's definitely beyond the
abilities of an ENB pilot looking for his next DNC.
What's the best DNC? Oh, it's the Zeno sport.
I'll find that one. And so that's why these limits
are put in to limit what manufacturers and develop to
make sure it doesn't distort what the Pacifica true sports
league. And so by putting those 6.8
aspect 67 cells, it preserves the spirit VNC, even though a
lot of raw wings don't actually apply with it.
But photon has 71 cells. Is what sorry?
Oh, that's 71 cells. Correct, but the photon was
certified before the 1st of May this year, so it's allowed
forever. OK.
But if they research by photon now, it would not be allowed OK.
So the smallest in final. But look, we'll just make it 67
cells when it says it will fly identically.
The number of cells make much difference, so it should be
fine. Yeah, and I believe I've heard
groom it. I've no direct information, but
I've heard groom it. The photon tomb is in has been
played with CSC could fly now applies to photon, so just.
A good question for smaller players.
You can swim fly smaller if you want to in that case.
Yeah, as long as we certify all the winners certified before the
1st of May and to fly forever certified after the 1st of May,
you can fly it for the next couple of years.
If you want to fly in 2028 onwards, it has to add up the
certified after the 1st of May. It must have the aspect that it
has some number of cells. We just need to get the speed
and there's one. Yes, yeah, must have the speed
limits. Yeah, and the speed limit is
have to be done on manufacturer. So yeah, we can get.
There you go. There's actually warnings on
CSU. You're right machine, you're
right next. Be careful what you're buying
off of that. So hey Wol, we've got a very
short topics. I just want to say something
guys need. We're talking about trimming,
how to get fast and how to improve your glider.
Just keep in mind it's EMC. Just go and fly it, don't change
anything. If someone for the last two
years was better than you, it's probably the skills, not the
glider. And I'm talking also about
myself. I do still for the people I've
never beat before. So look at the skills they have
and try to copy that and improve your flying because I'm sure
it's got the glider. OK, there's 22 notes.
One or please two note called hilarious ones I've had in the
past. Paul Tackerts.
He just smashes the task that he's in the SRS or Stan
Ratzikowski does know him. He absolutely smashes it in
sports class. I remember both times we pulled
the gliders in trim checks, but the request for the pilots
whispering in our ear. They were both negative like
slow going to still not too true.
I'll certainly when I. Had penis as well.
But it was the. Austin on 95 dinners.
Yeah, our palace has smashed up his first season finance.
The major Lisa or Baptists who apply a lower, lower aspect wing
was trimmed to the limit perhaps, but modeling is
probably a lower aspect wing than the rest of those.
Sometimes it is better. So could you go, could you
disclose the dates and location or the next year at least?
Yeah, we plan to publish all the dates.
So I just got one of the events we haven't finalized yet.
But just for general information for you.
So it is 99.9% sure we're not going to Columbia Leinster here.
So don't go booking Columbia. I'm expecting to see an SRS
there, the British optician for those who vote, that's the same.
The winter open globe be Columbia, the winter opens going
to India, Panskani next year and the SRS will probably be in
Slovakia in March. So buy some heated gloves.
It's cold and I'm going from memory now.
So the hope is monologue confirmed the April, May in
Spain, but it's not confirmed that with the sports final is
July in Jamona. We've got Macedonia Kuruchevo
with August and we've got prime weeks in Kuruchevo this time the
same we can just have or we've been smashing the weather there,
so that should be a good one. And we've got Saint Andre in
September the next year, the year after, I can't remember
most of it, but we got World Sports Final, the June,
September Saint Andre again as well.
So Saint Andre SRS next year and the year after, the sports
finally. And after that, Ashley's a crash
for fuel. Would you prefer to see US World
Sports Final every year or every other year?
I keep going. Maybe I'll Chuck that whole
later. It's it's actually quite a
serious question because every year sounds good, but the
calendar for the top pilots, and there are several in this room,
it's bloody full. We've got a hyperfly World
Championships, we've got a Junior World championships, got
a sports World Championships, an open World Championships and
that's before you even start on the continental version,
national events. It's getting very full with
calendar for high level events. So our thinking at the moment
was every other year, but maybe I'll put out a poll, The
majority you've wanted every year, then it's your series as
much as anybody. So it's what we do.
I have. There you go.
Anything. Else just in the home investor,
it's one I'm being in the inhabits in Malta.
Where are you? To get to the world sports, it's
based, otherwise it's based based on your season finish.
So yeah, it's it's to get the best season position, you need
to come to at least 2 events. But I couldn't tell you, for
example, you have Baptists who's qualified because which is what
event, I guarantee you at the end of the season, he's going to
be in the top 100. Sean qualifies other ways as
well, but he will be in the top 100 as well there, especially if
this weather continues. Yes.
Of course world's that's coming in world WE is.
Unbike Navigating the French current.
Together, SE and Ender. OK, so, so this is well they
limit it's on the top pilots getting in.
So there's a tax. We want something.
So there's going to be a lot of interest from the PwC pilots to
come and steal the candy. So how do we stop them if we
need to stop them? So we could do in the wild parts
for the last four years of the SRS wild clouds finish next
year. There's no more wild cards being
offered for every event. The way we happen doing that,
the wild cards put there at the start such that are those good
if we got very good pilots in the sport do fly sport wings or
did you want to compete and then they suddenly store a place for
them suits them the SRS of wanting to compete.
But and then there was people like Powell Tacketts who
absolutely loves whatever he does For him.
It's a great project to get involved in.
So it's existing really for them guys.
But it got a bit crazy. I was getting up to 50 wild card
requests per event and it was taking our team three or four
days were to compile all this into sharks the committee to
then vote on the board and stop crazy.
So I I want a month of my life back next year.
So they want wild cast. You don't read them.
Every wild card we give stops the member going so we're not
doing it anymore. However, the partners, they run
out on wild cast for events and if it's their own event too,
that's to make sure that someone like Bruce could get here and
represent his his brand at the event of it.
So for next year, we're actually going to increase it to for them
for every event. However, does that mean Ono's
now going to get a wild card? No, because there's another
little sub clause to the manufacturer now.
Any pilot they put forward must have an SRS store already.
So if if they want to put Ono in, Ono's got to go and fly a
sports event somewhere else away from the SRS, achieve a score,
then come back to the SRS, we've got to show dwar, commit them,
then let's just turn them in. And there's the points is where
the S where the SRS has all the West press points at the moment.
So to get into the World Championships, it's your sports
W press ranking accounts. That's not absolutely true as of
today because at the moment Civ have not decided the entry
criteria to cast you won. But I could pretty much
guarantee especially as a few of us are in rude.
I think the agreement the sports W press is how you qualify to
get in to to lap non championships.
So those guys are going to have to earn their W press in sports
event and the average sports events giving out that third
voice. We're giving out 75 points per
com. So they want to thumb to us.
They're not yet the wild charges.
They have to go and qualify. Another way to come to us to
give some commitment to SRS. Well, that'll slow them down.
But this is the racing series. It's going to get more serious
every year, so try and keep up. For you like that, but it's more
just competition hungry so. Yeah.
So other ways to get it to the SRS.
So at the moment you just buy a sports wing in any event and you
get an SRS store. So you can go to the French Open
or whatever high level open it is as long as you do it on a
Scorch wing. It creates an SRS store for you
to help qualify. However, of course, if you go to
the French photo and on a photon, you're probably coming
almost last about how good you are.
Even pow tackle it. Say that again in the top half
of that on them are Enzo's and plus 18 go true.
So the other ways to get in, we created this year 3 SRSS and SRS
qualifying events and three SRS. It could still be open both of
those so it still have end zones in it, but you will get a 50%
better SRS stores result or whatever it calculates to be 20
points will make it 30 and 200 points get to 300.
The same multiplier views in an SRS and a pre SRS means the
organiser intends to run an SRS in a future year and then the
other one's SRS qualifier. Qualifiers is the same formula,
but it just means that only using that to give out SRS
scores to their local pilots. It's not, they're not
necessarily intending doing an SRS in the future.
So that's the other two placing go.
So for example, if any of you want to fly after this event,
we've got a two week gap, then it can go to say Andre, we've
got the British Sports Championships there and it's an
SRS qualifier. Your whatever you score there
50% better quite so it would otherwise be and it's all sports
wins. So if you fail to qualify here,
you've got another chance to qualify there.
I mean fails qualified and to the events the moment need about
350 score to guarantee an SRS. If it's less than that, some
events are going less. The ozone addition if France
went down to about 100, some zeros actually got into that
one. It's getting harder for the
premium of this. Yeah, the sound was crazy.
That's 400 that you did to get dishonors to show it close I
think. Peace, Yeah.
Beasts. Yeah.
So, so there you go because you're down 11 and anymore was
it that a stronger? So there you go.